Speaker 1: Speaking of governors running for
president, did you know that it's actually against
the law for Ron DeSantis to run for president
unless he resigns his governorship? There is a
Florida law that forces governors to resign if
they want to run for president of the United
States. So what is Ron DeSantis going to do?
Well, it's looking like Republicans in Florida are
looking at changing that law specifically so that
Ron DeSantis could remain governor while running.
Now, you might say. But, David, I remember
that Jeb Bush remember the please clap guy.
Jeb Bush was governor and he ran for president.
That's true. But Jeb Bush was not governor at
the time that he was running for president. He
had previously been a governor. So let's take
a look at an article that explains what's going
on w FSU Public Media reported a couple of months
ago. Florida leaders are considering a change
to the resigned to run law to help Governor Ron
DeSantis. Ron DeSantis may need some help from the
state legislature if he proceeds with this bid for
the Republican nomination. A resigned to run law
requires. Eight office holders to commit to leave
their positions if they run for federal office.
This has been on and off the books over past
decades and was reinstated in 2018. But Republican
leaders in the Republican dominated dominated
legislature have expressed openness to changing
or rescinding it when they gather again in March.
That's this month. Florida House Speaker Paul
Renner told reporters it was a, quote, great idea
to review the law. Senate President Kathleen Pass
a Domo similarly said changes to the resignation
requirement would be a good idea. If an individual
who's a Florida governor is running for president,
I think he should be allowed to do it now.
DeSantis for now, has a way around this. And, you
know, one of the things we've been talking about
has been is DeSantis actually going to announce,
is he really planning to run? And it seems the
answer is yes, because of all of the events he's
doing in critical early voting states. But when
is he going to announce? Part of the reason he
may delay the announcement at least until April
is that this month Florida is going to meet about
this resign to run law. In the meantime, the
way DeSantis can sort of like start running is
by doing all of these stops under the umbrella
of being book tour events. But really, they are
early presidential type events. In fact, a Fox
News had an article this morning about how Ron
DeSantis has already been to Iowa and he's been
to Nevada and now he's going to New Hampshire. So
these are in practice presidential campaign type
events. But for now, and it may only be a matter
of a few more weeks, Ron DeSantis would have to
resign in order to run for president. Florida's
looking at changing that clearly and specifically
for Ron DeSantis. So we're going to follow that.